charrier merci d'être avec nous y at il
une manoeuvre d'encerclement de kiev oui
l'armée russe avait comme d'habitude te
prendre les villes en règle générale on
se débrouillant pour que le maximum de
civils s'en aille et en coupant le
maximum en fait dax à 7 à la capitale
alors là il y en a encore un qui encore
un peu dégagé et on a eu des montées en
fait par le haut et sur elle et sur le
côté et clairement ce qu'on voit c'est
que on est avec des chars qui sont en
train de monter c'était les dernières
images qu'on avait hier et que pour
l'instant on n'est jamais dire dans les
banlieues se dire qu'on a encore des
avenues qui ont encore de l'espace encan
d'une capacité de montée ainsi après la
ville ce sera autre chose parce que là
on sera dans des plus petites rues là il
peut y avoir des snipers il peut y avoir
des recoins donc là le char n'est
absolument plus en capacité de vraiment
de combattre et donc dans ces cas là il
faut des opérations qui sont différentes
c'est pour ça qu'en fait les choses se
font lentement ce qui a frappé
effectivement c'est le fait qu' on est
en plein sommet de versailles et même si
on a des inquiétudes
on voit bien que rien ne se prépare pour
aujourd'hui ou pour demain il vous
pensez que par des sacs de sable ça peut
freiner à la progression des chars après
ce qui est évident c'est que la
population se prépare kiev la capitale
c'est le symbole c'est pouvoir et elle
est partie dans la partie j'allais dire
de l'ouest de l'ukraine donc les
combattants et les habitants de kiev ont
choisi de rester et ils ont choisi de
combattre les russes alors il met le
maximum de choses qu'ils peuvent c'est à
dire effectivement le maximum de
barricades déjà ça arrête s'arrêtera pas
un char évidemment si vous êtes sur une
avenue dans une crypte idylle bien
forcément ça ça stoppe la progression
même à pied et puis ensuite vous avez
des personnes qui s'arme avec ce qu'ils
ont donc est en fait si on se rend
compte que jusqu'à présent ils ont aussi
une habitude de l'armement parce que on
n'acquiert pas ainsi une capacité de
tirer avec un missile antiaérien avec un
missile anti char ou avec un
lance-roquettes donc il ya
indiscutablement depuis 2014 la notion
de mini c'est en quelques sortes y reste
après il ya des gens qui n'ont jamais
combattu qui vont certainement découvrir
des choses si on va jusque là qui vont
être assez compliqué n'oubliez pas qu'en
plus
il y as parce que les images qu'on
voyait hier quand on voyait un peu
l'école d'arrivée c'est qu'il ya aussi
l'appui de drones en fait qu'ils sont
les drones turcs qui ont été données qui
là encore donne un avantage aux
ukrainiens le plan progression de
l'armée les russes auraient changé de
stratégie elle connaîtrait des loupés
également qu'en est il réellement alors
le plan russe on ne connaît pas on le
découvre forcément au fur et à mesure de
ce qui est en train de se passer mais on
voit que vladimir poutine à la carte de
l'ukraine parfaitement en tête il a
récupéré la partie qui lui était à la
plus essentielle c'est à dire autour de
la mer d'azov est en fait il ya
plusieurs fronts il continue à voir
toutes ces axes tout ce qu'il est en
train de faire du côté de mario paul par
exemple qui est absolument nécessaire
pour lui de maintenir au dessin il joue
davantage avec parce que ça peut être
aussi une marche de manoeuvre qui peut
avoir par rapport à kiev et en même
temps il veut pas se disperser parce que
s'il faut faire une avancée sur kiev
elle reste importante ensuite on a une
prise ou du nord qui sont les grands
noeuds en fait ferroviaire et donc du
côté de john hughes et puis de co2 top
qui colle au top est tombé et charnie
qui est encore entre d'un peu dans les
combats mais ça c'est la logistique
russe qui arrivent par là donc ils ont
besoin d'avoir les des passages en fait
de reiki son nom ce coin là et c'est
pour ça aussi que les ukrainiens essaie
de défendre ça c'est peut-être quelque
chose aussi il ne s'attendait pas qu'ils
aient autant de résistance ensuite sur
l'avancée effectivement qui se fait à
l'intérieur on a une partie de
l'information n'a pas tous les
ukrainiens comme unique effectivement
sur le nombre d'avions qui ont été
abattus le nombre d'hélicoptères le
nombre de chars toujours du côté russe
alors il ya une partie qu'on peut
recouper il ya une partie qu'on ne peut
pas recoupé parce qu'on n'a pas d'image
n'a pas forcément toutes les notions etc
et les ukrainiens en revanche même
lorsque le à l'occasion de discuter avec
eux en off mais qu'on avec des autorités
officielles
il ne refuse de donner les pertes qu'ils
ont chez eux owni me aussi bien humains
qu'au niveau de l'armement donc on voit
qu'on est on va monter sur une bataille
avec quand même une inquiétude qui est
que il ya effectivement les drones qui
sont turcs qui sont rentrés là-dedans
peut-être des avions si tout ce monde
commence à arriver là aussi et une de
plus en plus d'armements les américains
ont voté hier une enveloppe de 14
milliards de dollars d aide à l'ukraine
il y en a 4 milliards pour à l'aide
humanitaire est en fait il y en a 10
milliards qui reste en grande partie
pour l'armement et la reconstruction ce
qui vous laisse à penser que ça va être
effectivement si ça doit durer des
combats qui vont être extrêmement
violent merci beaucoup armelle charrier
pour votre analyse merci à vous las